All right, Michael. So, I think that brings us
to the end of what I wanted to talk about
anyway. So, can you help me remember what it is
that we've learned today? In particular, what you've learned today?
>> Sure. So, I guess the first think I learned is
that game theory can make you depressed. And, in fact, in
particular that my friend Charles, given the opportunity. Would totally drop
a dime on me just to save a month of incarceration.
>> Yeah.
>> Wait, no,
no, no, I don't think you summarized that
correctly. Game theory is not depressed. It's depressing.
>> Oh, yeah. That's a good point, that's a good point.
>> And Michael is not cruel. He is the victim of cruelty.
>> I don't think so. Because you want to know what the secret here is,
Michael? You've got a little matrix of
numbers. Those number capture what's going on.
The truth, Michael, is that, if we were in Prisoner's Dilemma. I would cooperate
with you because my utility is not simply the number of months that I
would spend in jail. But it's the number of months you also would spend in jail.
>> Oo. Interesting.
>> So if I, the best way to
beat Prisoner's Dilemma, is to change the numbers.
>> [LAUGH] I see. It's like the Kobayashi Maru of game theory.
>> Exactly. So there's an interesting question for you
right there, Michael. If I had prisoner's dilemma here, here,
let's write it out so you can remember. If I
had prisoner's dilemma here, we already know that we're going to
end up here, because that's what the numbers tell
us to do. But what we'd have to do
is change the game. So how would you change
the game in prisoner's dilemma? I see. So, if, if
we're thinking about it in particular in terms of
I care about how long you spend in jail.
Maybe not as much as I care about how
much I spend in jail. Like maybe half as much.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Then, the payments shift, right?
>> Right.
>> So, now we have like minus1 and a
half, minus 1 and a half in the upper left
hand corner.
>> Mm-hm. Minus 9 comma minus 4.5, minus 4.5, minus 9 and minus 9, minus 9.
>> So, yeah.
>> So now that, that bottom right becomes a lot
less attractive if we actually care about the other person.
>> Right.
>> Well that's, that's, that's, okay, I'm less depressed now.
>> Except of course, that requires that you feel that way internally and that
I feel that way internally. There's another
way that you could change the game here.
Which is, what happens to sniches in jail?
>> They are rewarded.
>> No. No they're not.
>> They're punished.
>> Yes.
>> Oh.
>> So, if your a part of the criminal fraternity, and you don't like
prisoners dilemma, then what you have to do is to create a system Where the
people who snitch get punished. So it's not just the months that they spend
in jail, it's everything else that's going to
happen to them if they drop a dime.
>> So
you're saying that minus 6, minus 6, ends up being worse?
>> No, what I'm.
>> No, the minus, wait, no, wait, what? Yeah. Oh, the
zero ends up getting, oh I see the zero ends up being
worse. Because even though your not in jail your going to get
I don't know somehow thwarted or, or punished for your past behaviors.
>> Accosted.
>> Interesting.
>> That's right. So that's
what you have to do and that works not just with criminals but with
the real world. Whenever your in this
sort of situation like a prisoners dilemma,
you can change the game by changing
everyone's utilities. Like for example hiring police
officer, police officers or hiring members of
the mob to take care of everything.
>> I see. So it almost seems like what
you're talking about is a kind of inverse game
theory, where if there's a particular behavior that I
want to see. How do I set up the payments and
rewards so that that behavior is encouraged.
>> Right, and by the way that has
a name, and it's called mechanism design. Mechanism design?
>> Yes.
>> I'm not sure I understand either of those words. [LAUGH]
>> Well, that's where you're trying to set up the set of incentives,
the mechanisms that you're using to pay people. You're trying to design them in
such a way to get particular behavior. This is what a lot of
economics is all about. This is what a lot of government is all about.
Tax breaks for example, for mortgage interest, encourages you
to buy a home, rather than rent a home.
>> I see, by changing the payoff structure.
>> Right.
>> Oh that's neat.
>> And so that's what we learned today. At least right now. [LAUGH]
>> Okay. Alright. So, let's see. So, just to try
to rattle off some of the other things. The whole
notion of Game Theory. We talked about, especially the idea
that. You can think about a game as a tree or
you could represent it as a matrix.
And, I believe you said, repeatedly, the matrix
has everything. Is that how you said it? Or the matrix is all you need.
>> Yip!
Let's see. We talked about minimax and maximin.
>> Mm-hm.
>> We, we relaxed a bunch of constraint on games.
>> So we, we looked at both perfect and hidden information.
>> Mm-hm.
>> We looked at both zero sum and non zero sum.
>> We learned a lot today. We looked at deterministic
and [UNKNOWN] I would want to say, but you called it non-deterministic.
And assuming that we can get rid of the first two
bullet items that look like maybe they were jokes. I would suggest
saying things like, we talked about what strategies are and that they
come in different flavors. We talked about the evil prisoners dilemma game.
>> Mm-hm. What else? You gotta give me more, otherwise it's [INAUDIBLE].
>> Oh, more, good point. Andrew Moore gave lots of really good examples that
>> yes.
>> Michael may be cruel, but Andrew Moore is awesome.
>> He's more cool than me. Andrew Moor is very
cool. All of the examples that we've used today, or almost
all of the examples we used today actually come from
Andrew Moore's slides. Andrew Moore is a professor at Carnegie Mellon
or at least he was before he went off to
Google. And is a really smart guy who cares very much
about machine learning. And game theory and produced a bunch
of slides that it turns out lots and lots of people
use in their own courses. And his examples were so good for game theory. That I
decided to coop them with his permission of
course. He tells everyone that they may use them.
And, in fact, we have pointers to the
slides in the resources links and folders for all
of you to look at. And I recommend
that you do. Did we learn anything else, Michael?
>> The only other thing that I would want to
mention is NASH which is a concept that is nashtastic.
>> It is nashtastic.
There are by the way, I should mention briefly. Other kinds
of equilibria concepts they're beyond the scope of this class. But
there's a whole lot more to game theory as you might
imagine. And sometimes when they ask you to in these situations where
you can't do what you want to do, you end up in
these prisoner's lemonade situations. Other kinds of equilibria can get you
out of it. And I'm going to argue without explaining why
that the way that they get around this is by introducing Other
ways of doing various kinds of communication. and, in fact, I claim they're
a particular part of mechanism design. But that's a topic for another day.
>> Okay. Fair enough.
>> Okay. Did we learn anything else, Michael?
>> I don't know. That's what I was thinking about. I mean, that seems
like a lot to absorb. And, the other thing is that repeated games, even
the prisoner's dilemma kind of unravel if you know when the end. And I
was going to look into what happens if you don't know when they're going to end.
>> Okay. So, I guess,
that will be something that we will learn. Next time.
>> Right, what we, what will we have will learned?
>> Yes. Future past tense.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Alright, Michael, well, I think that's about it.
At least my brain is full. So I will talk
to you next time, and you get to lead what
I believe is the last full lesson of the course.
>> Oh, exciting. It is excuiting. Alright, well bye
Michael. You have fun. I'll see you next time.
>> Alright. Bye Charles.
>> Bye.